the president also tweeting today about
another firing one he believes was long
overdue the attorney for Peters talk
says the FBI fired the special agent
Friday over anti-trump text he sent to
his former lover also at the FBI during
the 2016 campaign this as the
prosecution rests in the trial of trumps
former campaign chairman chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge has our report
from Alexandria Virginia there's simply
no evidence of bias in my professional
actions FBI agent Peter struck who was
kicked off Special Counsel Robert molars
Russia probe for anti-trump texts was
officially fired by the FBI Friday
afternoon along with his former
colleague and lover FBI lawyer Lisa
Paige the two exchanged thousands of
texts where they criticized candidate
Trump and his supporters in a lengthy
statement strux lawyer sent the FBI's
deputy director overruled the bureau's
disciplinary review that recommended a
60-day suspension and demotion implying
it was political quote this decision
should be deeply troubling to all
Americans a lengthy investigation and
multiple rounds of congressional
testimony failed to produce a shred of
evidence the special agents trucks
personal views ever affected his work
struck testified under oath last month
not once in my 26 years of defending our
nation did my personal opinions impact
any official action I took this is true
for the Clinton email investigation and
for every other investigation I've
worked on it is not who I am and it is
not something I would ever do strux
attorney singled out FBI director
Christopher ray alleging Struck's
termination was a departure from typical
bureau practice and contradicts director
Ray's testimony to Congress and his
assurances ray laid out his approach at
a recent national security conference
I'm not gonna make decisions based on
yelling and screaming I'm gonna make
decisions based on the process in a
series of tweets the president
emphasized struck was a decision maker
in the FBI's Russia and Clinton email
cases just fired agents struck formerly
of the FBI was in charge of the crooked
Hillary Clinton sham investigation he
tweeted it was a total fraud on the
America
public and should be properly redone
though the Attorney General recused
himself from the Russia probe a senior
House Republican told Fox he can still
take action named an individual perhaps
a US Attorney or some or even a retired
US Attorney to investigate this agency
to have full access to have subpoena
Authority and to get to the bottom and
the top of all of this past misconduct
the FBI declined to comment today on
strux termination which is standard
because the bureau doesn't publicly
discuss personnel matters Bret you're at
the federal courthouse there in
Alexandria where the Paul Manafort trial
taking place some movement today well
that's right Brent I just over an hour
ago the prosecution rested its case
after calling two final witnesses
including a Treasury Department official
who took the stand for a second time and
testified that Paul Manafort and his
business partner Rick Gates the
government's star witness never filed
paperwork to document the foreign bank
accounts for their company the judge
said he was allowing the testimony but
warned the jurors that the government
had the chance to indict manna for its
company and chose not to
only mr. manna quarters on trial and we
expect tomorrow morning to learn whether
defense will call its own witnesses and
reveal its own evidence Bret will follow
all that tomorrow Katherine thank you